- [Deborah] Well thank
you all for coming today.
I appreciate that's, I'm
hearing like, seven things,
so hopefully I'll be able
to stay focused here.
We'll see how good that works.
But hopefully I'll get your
attention first when we start
off with, what if I told you,
and maybe you agree with
that many businesses
are using gen AI wrong.
Maybe not the right
conference to say that at,
but I'm gonna go so bold to to say that.
I do believe, and actually
industry insight would tell us
that we're actually
utilizing gen AI wrong.
And maybe we could think
about something in the past
that actually tells us this is true.
So if you think about maybe
when electricity arrived.
You know, how did we want
to establish the history
of electricity?
The original intent of
electricity was literally
to make the room brighter,
but was that actually the best innovation
that we had from electricity?
We moved from candle to
light bulb, from light bulb
to generating power
plants, to power plants
creating new cities to cities,
creating new opportunities
for us around the globe.
So when you think about what
perhaps started out as a candle
to a light bulb, amazing
innovation, I'm not trying
to diminish the light
bulb, amazing innovation.
However, the real transformation
of light became when we actually started
to exploit what that was.
And I would say that
today in gen AI world,
we're actually facing a similar moment,
not to actually improve
the old, which is what
a lot of people are focused
on, but how do I identify
the new?
And so as we think about that
today, we're gonna talk about
what have you done with gen AI?
And more importantly,
who's going to imagine
what we have yet to do?
And again, for me, that is
the most important thing
that we can take away from
this is thinking about
what we accomplish.
So where to start?
As we think about gen
AI, one of the things
I wanted to talk about for a
moment are the three different
levels of gen AI.
A lot of things that, again,
many of you have probably heard
about, the three levels as
we sit there and talk about
is how do we unpack that Gen AI?
We have summarizing existing data sets,
repacking data into insights
and finding new insights
and collaborations.
And we know that most
organizations today, actually 75
or north of 75% of them are
focused on the first two.
And if we use that example of
my candle to the light bulb,
you'd realize that again,
perhaps the true value is in number three.
One and two are table stakes.
Again, not diminishing the
importance of them, table stakes.
But let's unpack it for a minute.
Show of hands maybe how many
of you have your greatest ideas
baked on a baked strategy,
greatest ideas, most impulsive ideas?
Does it align to your strategy
or is it maybe when you're
in the forever shower
or you're taking a jog or
you're not tangled to your desk?
It's all baked in a strategy.
So yes, you have a strategy,
but most of your best ideas
actually come from the edges
when you're actually
not thinking about that.
When you're allowing people
to think outside of what
they're most known to think about.
We tend to run our businesses based on
a very regimented strategy.
What I will tell you is actually
that's eclipsing number one
and number two, it's actually
not allowing number three
to happen at its fullest extent.
So we're gonna uncover
a couple of examples
where we might be able to help
your organizations look at
number three.
When we think about status quo.
Status quo today is
built on linear thinking.
And so if I were to ask how many
of you are non-traditional,
non-linear thinkers?
A lot of people raise their hands,
particularly in the tech field.
However, most organizations are not built
for non-linear thinkers.
Actually almost no
organizations, I won't say all,
but most are non built
for non-linear thinking.
When you think about
the hard work, how many
of you are stuck in pilot purgatory,
as everybody likes to call it?
You don't have to do
all the show of hands,
but latest statistics would say 95%
of organizations are
stuck in pilot purgatory.
I would argue that part
of the reason for that
is that we haven't done the hard work
of actually changing the infrastructure
to actually enable people
to think non-linearly.
Gen AI is built on
non-linear thinking, right?
Everybody's been talking about,
well we did this with cloud
or we did it with cyber,
we've done it previously.
Those are actually all technologies
that are built on linear thinking.
They're 0's and One's thoughts.
They actually are predicting
an if then statement.
AI, as we all know, is not.
It's an unpredictable learning mechanism.
So how is it and why are
we surprised that 95%
of our pilots are stuck in purgatory?
They're working on an infrastructure
and an organization that's
built for linear thinking.
So how do we actually disrupt
that a bit to enable us
to think about the edges
and actually do some
of the harder work?
Which again I would argue
would be restructuring your
organization, restructuring
your infrastructure
and unlearning the things
that you think you know.
So as we think about that,
what is this productive unpredictability?
Again, I've talked to countless amounts
of whether it be executives or architects
or just humans who are
interested in gen AI.
The value of AI is that it
actually democratizes innovation.
It allows people who don't
necessarily need to be coders
or thinkers or people
educated in AI tech to be able
to actually explore.
But again, when you think
about organizations,
those organizations
aren't necessarily built
to not just envelop that thought,
'cause if I were to ask
any of you, how many
of you appreciate diverse thinking?
I hope all of you raise your hand
and say we appreciate diverse thinking.
But again, the organizations
aren't built that way.
Performance expectations
Infrastructures aren't built to learn.
People aren't built to advance
because they think you
should have a certain title
or a certain role or a certain goal.
All those things put parameters
on unpredictable thinking.
So again, if we go back to the notion
that AI is built on unpredictability
and it will truly thrive
in unpredictable ways,
if the organization and the
infrastructure isn't built
to support that, we're
limiting our thinking.
I would say we're limiting our opportunity
and we're actually doing things based on
what we think we know
versus allowing our egos.
And I mean that 'cause
everybody has an ego,
it's a good thing.
It's a good thing to have egos.
Is to put that aside to unlearn
what you think you know.
So when we think about how
to go about doing that.
So as I often think about, you know what,
what can people do?
I get asked a lot.
"Yeah, I believe in all that, Deb.
I believe in non-linear thinking.
I believe in changing our infrastructure,
but we don't know what to do."
I constantly get told by people
that they're stuck in cement.
And so I look at how do we unharness
or harness the unpredictable thinking?
A couple, I'll talk through a couple
of different assumptions that again,
I would say we need to unlearn.
So thinking about how to spot the edges.
I dunno about you, but we all
say we wanna spot new talent.
Look at examples like boards.
Most boards are set up by people
that are sitting in executive management,
not actually new people who
could bring new thinking
and or new processes to
enable that new thinking.
And it's not to say that
boards are bad things,
it's to say again, how do we
rethink structure to be able
to not just spot the edges,
but to be able to
translate them into sparks.
I often have this conversation
with people who are like,
"We need to do an ideathon, a hackathon."
How many of you do that
to come up with ideas?
The number one problem with hackathons
and ideathons, they
actually almost never get
implemented and they almost
never actually all scale.
So if you were an employee who
came up with an amazing idea
in this hackathon, how do you
think it feels for that person
to never have anything come
to fruition with their idea?
So when we think about is
the system, in that instance
of the hackathon or the
ideathon, matching the outcome,
we actually wanna change our organization,
bring ideas to fruition.
What usually happens in those?
I mean I'll tell you 'cause
I've been part of many of them.
What usually happens
is you tell the person
with the brilliant idea that
their idea is brilliant,
but we can't do anything with it.
I dunno about you, but that
probably defeats the purpose.
So if instead how do we
actually look at bending that
and using AI to help enable those humans
who have these amusing ideas
to bring them into fruition?
But we're seeing a lot on
the gen AI front right now.
Again, table stakes for
operational efficiency.
Most of that operational efficiency
is to automate existing processes.
Why are we not stopping to say,
do we need the process at all?
Why do we not stop and
say, is there a better way
to connect these dots
so that perhaps instead
of just automating the broken process,
we actually are looking at
completely restructuring the way
we think and the way that we operate
to not just get operational efficiency,
but to actually create net new processes
that will actually be able
to spot people at the edges.
So harder work but bigger
return on the outside.
The other one is how do
we translate the sparks?
So again, you don't have to show of hands,
but how many of you got
your greatest insight
from a pilot or a prototype?
If you did, how did you
actually put that into action?
Again, the statistics are high.
Seven out of 10 pilots and
prototypes that are found
are often not actually put into execution.
And I would say based on other research,
the numbers are actually even higher.
So why is that?
Is it because a person
didn't like the idea?
Is it because the system
and the organization
wasn't allowing it to happen?
But we do it over and over and over again
because we want predictability.
The question I'll also ask, how
many of you need a playbook?
Okay, playbooks are things of the past.
AI can't work on a playbook.
It's not built to build
on a playbook, right?
Again, back to the unpredictable learning.
But as organizations we are
used to having playbooks.
How do we run it? How do we scale it?
How do we thrive it?
Is there a playbook for that?
Is there a rule set for that?
How instead do we
actually start to question
how do we have creative thinking?
So perhaps we don't need a playbook,
but that doesn't mean we have chaos.
Chaos actually turns to a very different
trajectory if not actually
managed in some way.
And the last one is how do
we embed the breakthroughs?
So the best thing I love
to talk about is metrics.
Again, you don't have to show of hands,
but if we were to talk
about metrics, how many
of you have been told
that your best metric
for AI implementation is speed?
My follow up question would be,
how many of you know your actual baseline
for what you're measuring speed against?
Almost nobody does by the way.
And so when you sit there
and think about that,
if you're told you need to
get AI into the implementation
into your environment faster,
faster, faster, faster.
Fast was never a metric
unless you actually know
what you're measuring it.
So again, how do we rethink metrics?
How do we rethink performance?
How do we rethink if we do
need it fast, what is fast?
Is fast in seconds, is fast in months,
is fast the same for my
company it is for your company?
What does fast mean?
Because we're running towards this notion
of fast without actually
understanding how to embed
breakthroughs into our organization.
So again, I often get the question of,
"Okay Deb, these all
sound great, like logical,
but we can't do that in our organization."
Again, why?
It's typically because
we want the status quo
and we don't like to have friction.
AI will inevitably create friction.
It does, it's positive friction.
And I would say embrace that chaos
because positive friction
actually can create change.
We are afraid of what we don't know.
I sat on board last
week, fortune 50 company,
and the organizations like,
"Deb, we don't even understand
how to utilize gen AI."
We spent 15 minutes
utilizing AI to be able
to create a candy company.
They're not in the candy
business by the way,
but just to create a candy company.
We did demographic research,
we created a presentation,
I had a jingle and a logo.
We did all kinds of things in 15 minutes.
And I did it simply so
that people could start
to understand the value
of what they could see.
I also did the opposite though.
It's not just letting AI
run for the sake of AI.
How do we actually make
them understand things
around hallucinations,
and how do you actually think
in an unpredictable scenario?
So we created this candy company
that all of a sudden I had
taking over the world in
about seven and a half minutes
to help show the point of now how do you
think about hallucinations?
How do you start to think
about what AI is learning
when you're not paying attention to it?
How do you start looking at AI
and asking different questions
so that if you have a space
or a typo by the way, you
get a different answer.
These are things that people
aren't paying attention to
because they're like, "Yeah,
it's great, I can type
and misspell and I still get an answer."
So I went to another screen, I said,
well what if you type it correctly?
Do you realize you get two
very different answers?
Do you also understand that
you have hallucinations?
If I happen to word my question
and ask what kind of pet
should I get tomorrow?
If I happen to put an
infer that I like a cat,
I'll get a cat as an answer.
If I happen to infer I get a
dog, I get a dog as an answer.
I'll ask again by show of hands, how many
of you thank your AI?
Most people don't.
If you thank it, you get better answers.
So there's lots of ways here that yes,
AI is going to allow us
to democratize innovation
and put new technology
into our organizations,
but you have to understand how to now
kind of sort of manipulate
this unpredictable learning.
So I did this whole candy
store in seven minutes,
and then we did it again
with all misspellings.
I misspelled the whole thing
and we got a totally
different candy company.
And I said, "These are the
things you need to understand,
not because you should
be afraid of using AI
or allowing people to play around with it
or do different things
with it, but understand
what it really means to
have human in the loop."
Historically, when we think
about human in the loop,
we think about a human in
the loop like as a checks
and balances.
You had five things, I
need to have five things.
Human in the loop in an AI
world is not just checks
and balances, it's you
looking at that scenario
and saying, "Did someone write the AI code
And all of a sudden I ended up with a dog
when I wanted to have a cat?"
And so understanding what that
difference is super important
as we think about how to
put these into practice.
And so I'll spend a little
bit of time talking about
how you can actually go
about doing it realistically.
So as we forge this path,
and I know we're talking
a little bit about gen AI,
but it would be applicable
for broader AI, agentic AI,
the number one thing
that we tend to get is,
"Well, it's gonna replace people."
It will change our talent
trajectory as a co-pilot.
I don't actually ever talk
about it in the factor of like,
humanity will be gone tomorrow.
It is actually a co-pilot for us
as we think about innovation.
So how do we spot the
things that others overlook?
I'm often an outlier. I love it.
I wear that with a badge
of honor to be an outlier.
But we want other outliers.
We want to be able to
spot that there are people
who are hungry to bring new
ideas into your organization.
It's not always easy as
we think about traversing
an organization, again,
there's performance metrics,
there's titles, there's roles,
there's things that fit
into neat little boxes.
There's homework that needs to be done
to restructure organizations
while we're working on
operational efficiencies
and we're working on all the table stakes.
The competitive advantage is gonna be
to create new businesses.
It is.
The business that you see today
probably isn't gonna exist
in that same way 3, 5, 10 years.
I actually would think
three to five years,
studies would say 10 years,
but at some point in time in the future.
Most people will say, "Well
Deb, that's not my problem,
it's the next leader's problem."
It's everybody's opportunity.
Flip the script, unlearn what
you think you know to be able
to get there.
To that point, how do
you translate discoveries
into new ways of working?
I'm a huge believer of sandboxes,
but I'm a huge believer
of sandboxes in actually
representing your organization.
Most sandboxes, again, I
think it's eight out of 10,
don't replicate your current environment
by people process, technology,
infrastructure, ecosystem,
third parties.
Part of what's gonna be advantageous
as we think about an AI forward world
is gonna be an ecosystem.
What better place to talk about
that on this floor when
all you see is ecosystems,
but I mean looking at your
competitors as your partners,
not as competitors.
What you think is competitive
advantage is probably not
gonna be competitive advantage in a year.
And I don't say it to be like,
we should all be worried,
concerned, dystopian.
It is to look at the opportunity.
How do you unlearn what
competitors mean in this world
of AI?
And then lastly, embed what works.
We're very afraid to
put gen AI directly into
an environment and actually test it.
Test it and learn from it,
test it and learn from it
and make decisions in 30
days, 45 days, 90 days.
It's not the traditional six months.
I don't know about many of you,
how many of you walk through an airport,
a bathroom, a doctor's office,
you see the happy button.
So those buttons like,
"Are you happy today?"
I'm like, "I don't know, I
just walked out of the bathroom
of an airport.
I don't know if I'm supposed to be happy."
But the way that this is doing
is because in today's age,
the constant feedback loop.
So your consumer, your customer
wants constant feedback.
They wanna be involved in the
process, they wanna understand
what your product is
gonna look like tomorrow.
The question for you as leaders
and as organizations, are
you gonna change your product
development lifecycle?
Are you gonna actually
take all that feedback?
What happens if you lose your customer?
Can I utilize AI to change
what this experience is?
Consumers want more impact.
They want more input.
I start hitting the unhappy button a lot,
will I get an email?
Will I have input into
what this new bathroom
is gonna look like?
Candidly, no, nothing actually happens.
I've gone and talked to some
of those companies as well.
I'm like, "What are you expecting?
What's your metric?"
And candidly, their metric
is like, just a happy place.
I'm like, "Well, what's happy for me
might not be happy for you."
So again, what's the
metric of measurement?
And then as we think about
what the future holds
and we think about
automating predictability,
I am the hugest believer
in opportunity here.
My mother died when I was young
and no child should ever have to suffer
anything of that nature.
And if we can use technology
to solve for problems
that we've never imagined solvable,
we are in that moment right
now to be able to solve
for tomorrow.
So all these are to say of diving in
and how to make that work.
The winners, quote unquote, won't be those
that automate the unpredictability out.
It's gonna be those that
can actually embrace
what predictability thinks about
and unpredictability by design.
How do you build that
unpredictability into your people,
into your process, into
what an org structure
even looks like.
I was working with somebody
a couple weeks ago,
what if we got rid of an org structure?
Three people in that
conversation's mind exploded.
They're like, "We can't get
rid of an org structure.
What would happen?"
I'm like, "I don't know,
what would happen?"
Perhaps we can scenario
what that would look like.
Perhaps we could use AI
to help us figure out
what that would look like.
But are we willing to break
what we think we know in order
to see the biggest amount
of competitive advantage?
I'd encourage all of you to
think about all the amazing
ideas you've had.
Again, likely in the shower
on a run, doing something that
where your brain is free to
be able to think about it,
and think about how you can
employ AI while still doing it
trustworthy, in a secure and safe fashion,
and at the same time showing that value
and showing that growth
to others around you.
That will be your competitive advantage.
With that, I'm like, talk like
the speed of light to be able
to get that done in 20 minutes.
I think I've got 60 seconds.
But that being said, that
is my discussion today.
If you have any questions
at all, please feel free
to find me or to find me on LinkedIn.
Otherwise, I greatly appreciate
all of your time today
and that's it.
So thank you.